- Deux mois après sa réélection,
l'appel d'Emmanuel Macron
aux Français à lui donner
une majorité forte n'a pas
été entendue.
Le chef d'État arrive en tête
au second tour des élections
législatives, mais très loinde e
qu'il souhaitait.
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a gagné
son pari et réussi à placer
l'Alliance des partis
de la gauche, appelé Nupes,
en la première force
d'opposition.
JEAN-LUC MÉLENCHON,
chef de file de la Nupes
- C'est une situation totalement
inattendue, absolument inouïe,
la déroui présidentiel
est totale et aucune majorité
ne se présente.
(acclamations)
Nous avons réussi l'objectif
politique que nous nous étions
donné.
- M. Macron qui n'a plus,
ni la majorité absolue,
ni la majorité relative,
eh bien, il ne va pas pouvoir
passer ses réformes tel qu'il
l'entend, parce que nous serons
là et nos députés seront là
pour se battre.
récompensés de
tous les efforts qu'on a fait
sur le terrain depuis plus de
deux mois. La Nupes s'est créée.
Aujourd'hui on est la premièreèe
force d'opposition à l'Assemblée
nationale, c'est historique.
(acclamation)
- Autre surprise :
la percée considérable
du Rassemblement national.
- Vive la République!
Vive la France!
(acclamation)
- Le parti de l'extrême droite
multiplie par 15 son nombre
de députés, une première
depuis plus de 35 ans.
MARINE LE PEN, cheffe de file
du Rassemblement national
- Nous incarnerons
une opposition ferme,
c'est-à-dire sans connivence,
mais une opposition responsable,
c'est-à-dire respectueuse
des institutions et
toujoursive.
Parce que notre seule et unique
boussole est l'intérêt de
la France et du peuple français.
- Ces élgislatives
ont encore une fois été boudées
par les Français; le taux
d'abstention devrait atteindre
près de 54 %.
Ici Marie-Michelle Lauzon,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.